hey youtubers is Charlie so this week
for my Game of Thrones bonus video I
wanted to talk all about Braavos because
we saw in the episode 60 so I thought
it'd be the perfect time to start and
because we're seeing it for the first
time on the show what I'm going to do is
talk about where it is geographically in
relation to Daenerys in Mereen as well
as the major organizations in its role
on the show if you're just finding me
for the first time each week I do bonus
videos for Game of Thrones in addition
to you know episode reviews and q and
A's be sure to subscribe to get
everything and feel free to leave me
suggestions for future bonus videos
first order of business because some of
you may have read the books please try
to be careful about posting spoilers in
the comments or at least use spoiler
tags just in case people are only
watching the show so we don't really
know how much the show is going to
change from the books but whenever I do
post my review later tonight I'll try to
talk about any changes they might have
made so wTF is Braavos have you seen any
of the trailers or the teaser for
episode 6 and you've probably seen this
guy the Titan of Braavos he's one of the
nine wonders of man inside the show that
is so he's actually modeled after the
Colossus of Rhodes the Titan is such a
symbol of their culture that he's even
stamped on all the Braavosi coins and
passing beneath him is the only way for
ships to enter the port city Braavos
itself is basically the most powerful of
the Free Cities and it exists way up on
the tip of the Eastern continent you can
actually see it on this map right here
physically the city exists inside a
lagoon you know on a series of small
islands connected by bridges remember
how Daenerys is in marine right now
she's way down here on the other side of
the continent it was formed about 500
years before Aegon's landing from people
fleeing the Valyrian expansion it's
nicknamed the bastard son of Illyria
just because the people that colonized
it were trying to hide from all the
dragons so it wasn't till after the doom
that Braavos really started to make
itself known to the rest of the world
because it's so critical to trade the
city's become one of the most powerful
and wealthiest in the world you know
thus the iron bank has become the
wealthiest bank in the world the most
notable locations in the city are the
Titan itself right here drowned town
which is an area where the city has
sunken into the lagoon the house of
black and white which is the temple of
the many-faced God they're actually
temples to a lot of different gods that
all exist in this area called the Isle
the gods so as you can see the temple of
roller Melisandre's God is here - here's
the purple Harbor which is really only
used by the locals it's near the sea
Lords palace he's the ruler of Braavos
then there's the iron bank here this is
actually where the scene with Mark
Gatiss from the episode 6 trailer takes
place
there's Ragman Harbor down here which is
used by most foreign traders visiting on
business and then there's the temple of
the moon singers so that's actually the
name of a religion but they were
actually the people that fled Valyria
and found the site where Braavos is
located right now so they technically
kind of founded the city there's a
billion different other locations you
can see on this map that are all really
interesting so the next time the show
does come to Braavos I'll go into
greater detail about some of these other
different places the most important
location right now is the iron bank just
because it's the common denominator
amongst all the biggest factions on the
show you cannot win the Iron Throne
without a war or a marriage and both
cost a lot of money which as we learn
from Tywin Lannister last week no one
has yeah the Tyrells are wealthy but
most of their assets are in farmland so
the only way to get more money on the
show right now is basically to borrow it
from the iron bank and just to give you
an idea of how powerful they are the
iron bank is more powerful than all the
other banks combined it's mostly known
for the way that it goes after debts
which is funny because you know up to
this point in the show we've heard the
Lannister motto so many times a
Lannister always pays his debts
well the iron bank's motto is the iron
bank will have its due
so because the iron bank always goes
after its that's really aggressively
what happens is when say a king refuses
to pay back his debt the iron bank finds
another person to install as a king
impacts them so potentially if the Iron
Throne does not repay its debt it's you
know massive debt to the iron bank the
iron bank might find someone else to
install as king of Westeros if that ever
did happen you know once they install
said new king you know that person still
has to repay the original debt or the
iron bank will do the exact same thing
and just find someone else to install as
king so when you think about it the iron
bank is really the most powerful
organization in the world you know even
the Iron Throne has to bow to them which
is why Stannis in the trailer almost
looks like he's begging
Mark Gatiss for money the conceit being
that Stannis might try to use the Iron
Throne stead to the iron bank as cause
for them to back his claim to the throne
I don't really know how the show is
going to deal with that plot but I'm
really interested to see what kind of
terms they set for Stannis if they do
end up loaning him money and remember if
Stannis does end up getting a loan and
does not repay his debt then they'll
just turn around and find someone else
to install who will repay that money
needless to say the iron bank controls
the flow of money and therefore it
controls the balance of war so based on
that teaser for episode 6 it's really
hard to tell which other places inside
Braavos we might see but here are a
couple possibilities in this shot of the
Titan you can actually see the sea Lords
palace in the background we might get to
see some water dancers or you know maybe
a few Easter eggs for some of the other
big places
remember how Arya was practicing her
water dancing for the Hound last week
Syrio Forel who taught at or was one of
the Bravo's just one Oh in that Braavos
there a group of people inside Braavos
the city there just a special class of
Fighters inside the city that developed
that water dancing technique they
dressed in really interesting you know
bright loud colors as you can see from
Serio here the wealthy people in the
city on the other hand dress and really
drab great colors as you can see Mark
Gatiss wealthy banker dressed here the
interesting thing about being part of
that you know Braavos fighter
organization is that anyone wearing a
sword after dark can be challenged to a
duel it's all about finding out who that
best fighter is they just challenge each
other constantly for bragging rights you
know as to best fighter in the city so
say someone like Syrio Forel probably
had to fight people every single night
and because he lived to a pretty decent
age it looks like it meant he was pretty
badass the place where most of them go
to duel is the moon pool right here on
the map as you can see right near the
iron bank so there is a good chance that
we might get to see at least a
background shot of it obviously sex
being a very big thing in the world of A
Song of Ice and Fire
Braavos has a very strong tradition of
courtesans which hold a very you know
special place in Braavosi culture they
command really extreme prices so just
think of the amount of money a prince
with say Oberyn Martell zappa tights
would spend you know kid in a candy
store all the best houses are
either up here in the purple Harbor or
around the moon pool so isn't it funny
that all the best sex is right
around the bank I guess it says
something about people's priorities yeah
sex and money you know seems about right
I'm really hoping do we get to see more
of the city this season just because
it's so much fun to talk about you know
of all the cities the show is depicted I
would say that this is the best with
Berean being number two even though we
haven't seen a lot of it yet in King's
Landing third unless you want to count
the lands of always winter we saw in
episode four that white Walker City
looked pretty sweet but now it's your
turn let me know what are you most
excited to see in Braavos in this next
episode I know a lot of Doctor Who and
Sherlock fans were just really excited
to see Mark Gatiss you know myself
included given what we know about his
character from the books I'm really
interested to see if he plays it more
like say Mycroft or if he's going to
play it a little bit lighter he
essentially has the task of showing us
what that motto means the iron bank will
have its due so I'm expecting him to
play a scarier version of Mycroft so
I'll be posting my review the episode
episode 6 after it airs tonight be sure
to subscribe to get that and I want to
say a big happy Mother's Day to all the
moms out there thank you very much for
everything you do everyone be sure and
call their mother even if it's Cersei
right now you can click here to catch up
on last week's episode and click here to
get my Q&A thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
[Music]
you